Hello, and welcome to a bonus episode of how we made your mother.
大家好，欢迎收看我们如何造就你母亲的额外剧集。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend, Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hello, very happy to be here.
你好，很高兴来到这里。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Always great to see you.
很高兴见到你。
Our producer, extraordinaire, Alec Levis with us.
我们的杰出制作人亚历克·李维斯（Alec Levis）和我们在一起。
And these episodes, we're calling general questions, general questions.
这些情节，我们称之为一般性问题，一般性问题。
These are questions we get from all over from our sub-stack page from Instagram when Alec posts questions about, you know, send us your questions about specific episodes.
当 Alec 发布有关特定剧集的问题时，我们会从 Instagram 的子堆栈页面上收到这些问题。
So these are questions about episode four, return of the shirt.
这些是关于第四集“球衣归还”的问题。
Is that right, Alec?
是这样吗，亚历克？
That's correct.
这是正确的。
We should probably discuss what saluting is.
我们也许应该讨论什么是敬礼。
I think the key to it is that the part where it comes up to you.
我认为关键在于这取决于你。
It's not the letting it go.
这不是放手。
I think it's more about this.
我认为更多的是关于这个。
You know, no.
你知道，不。
You know what?
你知道吗？
You're not serving the army.
你不是在为军队服务。
You're not.
你不。
Come on.
快点。
You can't.
你不能。
You invented the bit doesn't mean you own exactly what it means.
你发明了这个位并不意味着你完全拥有它的含义。
You invented the vet.
你发明了兽医。
You know, I do think we should work on our rhythm.
你知道，我确实认为我们应该按照自己的节奏努力。
I do think we should work on our rhythm.
我确实认为我们应该按照自己的节奏努力。
So when I say general questions, general questions, but let's try to link it up.
因此，当我说一般性问题时，一般性问题，但让我们尝试将其联系起来。
General why don't you say both words, say general questions.
将军为什么不说这两个词，说一般问题。
I did not.
我没有。
He did.
他做到了。
Be louder.
大声点。
Jesus, Alec.
天哪，亚历克。
Jesus Christ.
耶稣基督。
This is a show over your bit.
这是一场关于你的表演。
You're very proprietary over your bit.
你对自己的财产非常有所有权。
You got to these are episodes we're calling general questions general questions.
您看到的这些是我们将一般问题称为一般问题的剧集。
All right, that was closer So you can also go to how we made your mother.com go to meet some contact Tell us your story you can write it, but we would love it if you would record it Tell us what how I made it and what it means to you and also Any questions you might have about upcoming episodes We really want this to be a fan centered show.
好吧，那更近了所以你也可以去我们如何制作你的 mother.com 去见一些联系人告诉我们你的故事你可以写它，但如果你能录制它我们会很高兴告诉我们我是如何制作它的以及它对你意味着什么以及你对即将播出的剧集可能有的任何问题我们真的希望这是一个以粉丝为中心的节目。
We want to interact with you.
我们想与您互动。
We want to hear from you you, you're burning, burning questions and your observations and why you keep watching the show.
我们希望听到您的来信，您提出了一些迫切的问题和您的观察结果，以及您为什么继续观看该节目。
And if you're watching for the first time and something trips you up, ask us.
如果您是第一次观看并且有什么问题让您感到困惑，请询问我们。
And so this week, I put out some, let's call them instructions, best practices for, for getting your question into general questions here, general questions, questions, yeah, yeah.
因此，本周，我提出了一些，让我们称之为说明和最佳实践，以便将您的问题转化为一般性问题，一般性问题，问题，是的，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
We got to send our toast.
我们必须送上我们的祝酒词。
You know, we're trying to, we're trying to avoid yesterday no questions, right?
你知道，我们正在努力，我们正在努力避免昨天没有问题，对吗？
We have a lot of time here.
我们在这里有很多时间。
talk about things.
谈论事情。
We're trying to avoid too much, I guess we'd call it writing, right?
我们试图避免太多，我想我们会称之为写作，对吧？
Like, hey, would Ted like pepperoni or cheese pizza more?
就像，嘿，泰德更喜欢意大利辣香肠还是奶酪披萨？
You know, we're not sort of diving back into retelling stories.
你知道，我们并不是要重新开始重述故事。
But people had great questions.
但人们有很大的疑问。
I really encourage people to ask the big questions, right?
我真的鼓励人们提出重大问题，对吗？
They tell us the big stories about their lives.
他们向我们讲述他们生活中的重大故事。
We're interested the big questions.
我们对重大问题感兴趣。
Rich did also about production itself, what happened.
里奇还谈到了制作本身以及发生的事情。
So I just want to shout out, Bearet Adults, Bearet Adults, who just simply said, tell us everything, please.
所以我只想大声喊出来，Bearet Adults，Bearet Adults，他们只是简单地说，请告诉我们一切。
What I thought was lovely and a good start to the whole evening.
我认为这很可爱，是整个晚上的良好开始。
Okay, live bumpis from Instagram.
好的，来自 Instagram 的现场直播。
So obviously after all these years, Josh, you and the gang know each other so well as you're rewatching, is it strange to watch yourself interact with everyone before you actually knew them well?
显然，这么多年过去了，乔希，当你重新观看时，你和这帮人已经非常了解彼此了，在你真正了解他们之前，看到自己与每个人互动，是不是很奇怪？
That's a good question.
这是个好问题。
That's a great question that kind of like scrambles my brain a little bit.
这是一个很好的问题，有点让我的大脑有点混乱。
I mean, yeah, I guess by the mystery, by the fourth episode in actor land, you kind of feel like you do know each other well.
我的意思是，是的，我想通过神秘感，到演员之地的第四集，你会觉得你们确实很了解彼此。
Actors have an ability, I think sometimes to their detriment, but I would call it intimacy, you know, where you can kind of approximate intimacy rather quickly.
演员有一种能力，我认为有时会对他们不利，但我会称之为亲密感，你知道，你可以很快地接近亲密感。
It's why it's why actors can fall in love very quickly on set, but you can also become best friends very quickly or our German enemies very quickly.
这就是为什么演员可以在片场很快坠入爱河，但你也可以很快成为最好的朋友或我们的德国敌人。
And I think by the fourth episode, by this episode, I kind of felt like I knew these people.
我认为到了第四集，到了这一集，我有点觉得我认识这些人。
I knew Neil before because we had done a play together.
我以前认识尼尔是因为我们一起演过一部戏。
So by the time we were even shooting the pilot, I felt like I knew him.
所以当我们拍摄飞行员时，我觉得我认识他。
And it's nothing compared to what you feel by the ninth season when you really know people.
与第九季真正了解人们时的感受相比，这根本不算什么。
But I think the other thing is we were playing people who really knew each other well.
但我认为另一件事是我们扮演的是非常了解彼此的人。
So even though Barney and Robin were newer additions to the gang, saying, you know, me, Ali and Jason were approximating a relationship that was 10 years old at that point, you know, we met at freshman year of college.
因此，尽管巴尼和罗宾是该团伙的新成员，他们说，你知道，我、阿里和杰森当时的关系已经接近 10 年前了，你知道，我们是在大学一年级时认识的。
So I think that it's hard to say I think part of the job of the actor is to approximate the intimacy and the closeness and the longevity of the relationship, whatever it is, even though you just got hired and got thrown together on a sound stage.
所以我认为很难说我认为演员工作的一部分就是估计关系的亲密程度和持久性，无论是什么，即使你刚刚被雇用并在摄影棚里一起工作。
But I don't think it's something that I thought much about until this question.
但在提出这个问题之前，我认为我并没有对此进行过太多思考。
So I'm riffing.
所以我在即兴演奏。
That's what I got.
这就是我得到的。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Peter underscore Stuart 29 says, I presume wardrobe was a large part of the show.
Peter强调Stuart 29说，我认为服装是这场秀的重要组成部分。
When the shirt chosen as the shirt must have been part of the process, just how, just wondering how much input did you both have on clothing choices throughout the rest of the show?
当被选为衬衫的衬衫一定是整个过程的一部分时，只是想知道你们在整个演出的其余时间里对服装选择有多少投入？
A good chance to just talk about costume design.
这是谈论服装设计的好机会。
I'm curious.
我很好奇。
Do you remember a bunch of shirts were brought to you and you were helped you helped choose like this sort of distinctive.
您是否记得有人给您带来了一堆衬衫，并帮助您选择了这种独特的衬衫。
I have a vague memory of coming in and having like five or six shirts there and then I mean, I remember you basically you try them all on and the right one just kind of announces itself.
我有一个模糊的记忆，进来时有五六件衬衫，然后我的意思是，我记得你基本上把它们都试穿了，合适的一件就自然而然地出现了。
I think we I think we picked that shirt because it felt like a shirt that he wouldn't normally wear or gravitate to.
我想我们选择那件衬衫是因为它感觉像是一件他通常不会穿或被吸引的衬衫。
Yeah.
是的。
But it looked like it maybe was in the world of what he might have bought one random day or whatever, whatever store.
但看起来这可能是在他随机一天或其他什么商店买的东西的世界里。
But I think it, well, we, they would always take polaroids of you.
但我认为，好吧，我们，他们总是会拍你的宝丽来照片。
And then they would send them to you, right?
然后他们会把它们寄给你，对吗？
Like you would look over the costume choices.
就像你会检查服装选择一样。
And yeah, how rigorous were you with the costumes?
是的，你对服装有多严格？
Would you ding some stuff or were you just like, fine?
你会做一些事情还是只是想，好吗？
We ding stuff sometimes in Pam Wood or wonderful director Pam Fryman, she always had an eye on like, does that make sense?
我们有时会在帕姆·伍德（Pam Wood）或出色的导演帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman）身上寻找东西，她总是关注这样的事情，这有意义吗？
Is that that character?
是那个角色吗？
And like, and if you guys ever said something, that always meant a lot to me.
就像，如果你们说过什么，那对我来说总是意义重大。
Like I always, I would always say, but like, yeah, you need to feel it.
像往常一样，我总是会说，但是，是的，你需要感受它。
You need to feel it on your body, like you, so I, that's why I figured you were a part of choosing that shirt.
你需要像你一样在身体上感受它，所以我，这就是为什么我认为你是选择那件衬衫的一部分。
I think Carter might have been on sat that week, not me, Carter and I traded off who was where when running the show.
我认为卡特那周可能在周六，而不是我，卡特和我在主持节目时权衡了谁在哪里。
And so I don't think I was part of that choice, but I, I'm sure it was agonized over.
所以我不认为我是那个选择的一部分，但我确信它是痛苦的。
I'm sure there were a half a dozen shirts and there were discussions and debates about why that's not.
我确信有六件衬衫，并且人们对为什么不这样做进行了讨论和辩论。
There's that kind of thing where you, you, your fashion choices are, you know, minor, I have a pretty narrow band of like, I just wear kind of the same thing all the time.
有这样一种事情，你，你，你的时尚选择，你知道，很小，我的范围很窄，我只是一直穿同样的东西。
But like, if I do wear something like a little bit different, like I do kind of walk around expect to people to say hot top, bro, or like do you acknowledge like, oh, this, I'm looking at this.
但是，如果我确实穿了一些有点不同的衣服，就像我四处走动时希望人们说热上衣，兄弟，或者你承认吗，哦，这个，我正在看这个。
This is new.
这是新的。
I wore a tie-dye card again last week.
上周我又戴了一张扎染卡片。
And it's something I kick around the house to an Anna wears it a lot.
我在家里到处乱踢这件东西，安娜经常穿着它。
But I've never, I've worn it publicly.
但我从来没有在公开场合佩戴过它。
And I was shocked that you guys weren't like hot top, bro.
我很震惊，兄弟，你们不像热心人。
But if you want to see me in my tiny part again, which I love, by the way, retroactive hot topic.
但如果你想再次看到我的小角色，顺便说一句，我喜欢追溯热门话题。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Many days late.
迟到了很多天。
And that's sure it was a good choice because it did look notable on him, right?
这肯定是一个不错的选择，因为它在他身上看起来确实很引人注目，对吧？
And he wears it that whole episode and it feels like a little wrong, like not quite him.
他整集都戴着它，感觉有点不对劲，就像不完全是他一样。
Like he's trying to force it.
就像他试图强迫它一样。
It had to metaphorically be, I'm slightly forcing this thing that isn't meant to be, right?
打个比方，我稍微强迫了这件本不该发生的事情，对吧？
Because that was the metaphor.
因为那是比喻。
It looked like a guy who was like, they're going to someplace fancy and maybe a club, but he doesn't know how to quite dress for it.
看起来就像一个人，他们要去某个很高档的地方，也许是一个俱乐部，但他不知道如何穿得漂漂亮亮的。
So he's like, this is nice enough, right?
所以他说，这已经足够好了，对吧？
Like it was like a little upgrade.
就像是一个小小的升级。
And like, it's, it's a thing you put on.
就像，它是你穿上的东西。
You're like, this is nice, right?
你会想，这很好，对吧？
Like, you're not confident.
比如说你不自信。
It's like, it's, it's, it's, and you obviously come in and you write, right?
就像，它，它，它，你显然进来了，你写了，对吧？
Right?
正确的？
You, you get on board with it, but he's sort of convincing himself about it because it is kind of a weird shirt, right?
你，你同意了，但他有点说服自己，因为这件衬衫有点奇怪，对吧？
It does kind of jump out a little bit.
它确实有点跳出来。
He doesn't feel totally comfortable in it, which is the point of the episode.
他对此感觉不太舒服，这就是这一集的重点。
So like, if it was a shirt that, that you just look at and you're like, that is a great shirt.
就像，如果这是一件衬衫，你只要看一眼就会觉得，那是一件很棒的衬衫。
The whole episode kind of doesn't work like it doesn't be a thing that you're like you're drawn to it but ultimately it's not for you.
整个情节有点不怎么样，就像你不喜欢它一样，但最终它不适合你。
It's slightly off and eye catching and you can't decide if it's an eye catching in a good way or a bad way and the answer is it's kind of both.
它有点偏离并且引人注目，你无法决定它是好还是坏，答案是两者兼而有之。
Right.
正确的。
Yeah, so I think we nailed the shirt choice in that one actually in that regard.
是的，所以我认为我们实际上在这方面确定了衬衫的选择。
This goes a little bit to the flow of the production week, which we started to talk about last week, but Craig, how many days does, well, there's the whole crew, but let's just talk about costumes right now.
这有点与制作周的流程有关，我们上周开始讨论这个问题，但是克雷格，有多少天，嗯，整个剧组都有，但我们现在只谈谈服装。
How many days do they have before between getting the script and needing to have this thing ready to go.
从拿到剧本到需要准备好这件事，他们还有多少天的时间？
We would distribute the outline at a certain stage to production so they could sort of flag what some production needs would be and they would have known way ahead of time like there's a really featured shirt.
我们会在某个阶段将大纲分发给制作，这样他们就可以标记一些制作需求是什么，并且他们会提前知道，就像有一件真正有特色的衬衫一样。
The episode's also called Return of the Shirt so that's a heads out.
这一集也被称为衬衫归来，所以这是一个头。
But the things like that you sort of flag them as early as you could so there might be a couple weeks you know there might be even in a few weeks.
但是像这样的事情，你应该尽早标记它们，所以可能会有几周你知道甚至可能会在几周内。
But sometimes you have a completely last minute idea that's the rewrite you're doing for the episode that shoots Wednesday morning and it's Tuesday night at midnight.
但有时你完全在最后一刻有了一个想法，那就是你正在为周三早上拍摄的剧集进行重写，而周二晚上的午夜。
And we had in this amazing crack production crew and staff that could make that happen.
我们拥有出色的制作团队和工作人员，可以实现这一目标。
But yeah, with this, where this was the idea the whole time, they would have had a little bit of lead time.
但是，是的，有了这个，如果这一直是这个想法，他们就会有一点提前时间。
So I'm sure like they were selecting a batch of shirts.
所以我确信他们正在选择一批衬衫。
But yeah, I mean, the answer is it just varies wildly.
但是，是的，我的意思是，答案是变化很大。
And it's both in one episode.
而且这两件事都在一集里。
It could be they knew one part of it for many weeks.
可能他们已经知道其中的一部分好几个星期了。
And then we came up with something at midnight on Tuesday and they had to get it by Wednesday.
然后我们在周二午夜想出了一些办法，他们必须在周三之前得到它。
11 a.m.
上午 11 点
when we shot it, so it's all of the above.
当我们拍摄它时，所以就是以上所有内容。
That's what made it so chaotic and great.
这就是它如此混乱和伟大的原因。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my my car stereo when I'm in reverse.
或者，为什么我在倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量。
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客，或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
Well, heating the call for a big question and really getting into the concept, Josh, you had of this show originally, which is let's take the themes of this show and see where they spin us.
好吧，热烈呼吁提出一个大问题，并真正进入概念，乔什，你最初对这个节目的概念是，让我们以这个节目的主题为例，看看它们将我们带向何处。
Da underscore Matthew six five four says on this episode Ted reconnects with Natalie thinking it was a mistake to break up with her only to break break her heart again.
达强调马修六五四在这一集里说泰德与娜塔莉重新联系，认为与她分手是一个错误，结果却再次伤透了她的心。
Do you think nostalgia makes us see past relationships in a better light than they actually were.
你认为怀旧会让我们以比实际更好的眼光看待过去的关系吗？
I worked with this playwright years ago named Richard Greenberg who's a great, great writer.
几年前，我与一位名叫理查德·格林伯格的剧作家合作过，他是一位非常非常伟大的作家。
And he had this quote that I always think about when I think about nostalgia.
当我想到怀旧之情时，我总是会想起他的这句话。
He says, as nostalgia is simply a longing for a time we know we can survive.
他说，怀旧只是对我们知道可以生存的时代的渴望。
Great line.
很棒的线路。
That's the whole show.
这就是整个节目。
And in a way, that's what how I met your mother.
在某种程度上，这就是我认识你母亲的方式。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think the reason we're nostalgic for the past is because we made it through.
我认为我们怀念过去的原因是因为我们已经度过了难关。
And the future, I mean, think about it.
我的意思是，未来，想一想。
Like the 1980s, we thought we were gonna die in nuclear holocaust.
就像 20 世纪 80 年代一样，我们以为自己会死于核浩劫。
Like it was, that was a very real feeling.
就好像，那是一种非常真实的感觉。
Yes.
是的。
you look back at the 80s and you just think about like thriller and Cindy Lopper.
当你回顾 80 年代时，你只会想到惊悚片和辛迪·洛珀 (Cindy Lopper)。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like, like, it, uh, uh, Robex, like you, you just think about the, the decade.
就像，就像，呃，呃，Robex，就像你一样，你只想着这十年。
Yeah.
是的。
And then, like, why 2k, like, every generation has its kind of like apocalyptic dread, kind of just woven in, but we don't know if we're going to get out of this one.
然后，就像，为什么 2k，就像，每一代人都有一种类似世界末日的恐惧，有点交织在一起，但我们不知道我们是否能摆脱这一代。
But if we do 2050, we're going to look back at 2025 and be like, uh, a simpler time.
但如果我们到了 2050 年，当我们回顾 2025 年时，我们会发现，呃，一个更简单的时代。
It was a simpler time, wasn't it?
那是一个更简单的时代，不是吗？
It was a great time to raise children, you know?
那是抚养孩子的美好时光，你知道吗？
Oh my God, 2050 is gonna fucking suck it, apparently.
天哪，2050 年显然会很糟糕。
But that's the thing, it's like our brains, our brains do this weird thing, this kind of like it was easier back then, it was better back then.
但事情就是这样，就像我们的大脑，我们的大脑会做这种奇怪的事情，就像那时更容易，那时更好。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think Ted in that, in this episode is like, I can't figure out this moving forward thing.
我认为特德在这一集里就像是，我无法弄清楚这个前进的事情。
I don't like meeting new people and having to tell them all the old stories.
我不喜欢结识新朋友并向他们讲述所有旧故事。
Like you know that thing when you're dating, not you Craig, But that thing when you're dating and you're like, oh my God, I have to tell this woman all of the stories and like about my parents and like where I like, you wish you could have like a chip.
就像你在约会时知道的那样，不是你克雷格，但是当你约会时你会想，天哪，我必须告诉这个女人所有的故事，比如我父母的故事，比如我喜欢的地方，你希望你能有一块芯片。
You could just like inject into their neck and they went just download all the stories so you could just like move on.
你可以直接注射到他们的脖子上，他们就会下载所有的故事，这样你就可以继续前进。
But it's like a new thing.
但这就像一个新事物。
The Matrix Kung Fu thing.
矩阵功夫的事情。
Yeah, you just have to like, I know all Josh's anecdotes are in caught up.
是的，你只需要喜欢，我知道乔希的所有轶事都被追上了。
No, God forbid they know all the anecdotes, but I think there's something about, okay, I know what that's like.
不，上帝不允许他们知道所有的轶事，但我认为有一些东西，好吧，我知道那是什么样的。
And I think what we're scared we yearn for the familiar.
我认为我们所害怕的正是我们渴望熟悉的东西。
You know, we yearn for comfort.
你知道，我们渴望舒适。
I love that observation about this episode.
我喜欢对这一集的观察。
That is what the episode is.
这就是这一集的内容。
And we don't, again, we don't explicitly state it.
我们也没有明确说明这一点。
Maybe we could have stated it even more explicitly.
也许我们可以更明确地说明这一点。
But the drive to, I want to go back to something because I already had done the work.
但在开车的过程中，我想回去做一些事情，因为我已经完成了工作。
I already, the jar was loosened there, right?
我已经，那里的罐子松动了，对吗？
There's something to go back to.
有事要回去。
That's sort of Ted's secret drive in that episode, right?
这就是特德在那一集中的秘密动力，对吧？
I don't want to have to re-explain myself.
我不想重新解释自己。
Right.
正确的。
And also, I think kind of what we were talking about, like he really put his heart out there with Robin and got stomped.
而且，我认为这就是我们正在谈论的，就像他真的把自己的心与罗宾放在一起，然后被践踏了。
And now he's like, you know what?
现在他就像，你知道吗？
I did take a big risk with someone new.
我确实和新朋友一起冒了很大的风险。
So why don't I go back to, I mean, Ted does have, there's a runner where he likes cozy things.
那么我为什么不回去，我的意思是，特德确实有，有一个跑步者，他喜欢舒适的东西。
You know, he likes, like he likes the paper.
你知道，他喜欢，就像他喜欢报纸一样。
He likes a certain coffee shop or bagel shop.
他喜欢某家咖啡店或百吉饼店。
Like, there's all these things that he just like, he likes the familiarity and the roadness of certain things.
就像，他就是喜欢所有这些东西，他喜欢某些东西的熟悉感和路感。
Yeah, it's interesting.
是的，这很有趣。
In episode three and episode four, there's two in a row where he's clinging to something.
在第三集中和第四集中，有连续两集他紧紧抓住某物。
Like, he just wants to go to his normal bar.
就像，他只是想去他平常的酒吧。
Right.
正确的。
And Barney says, you're stuck in a rut and breaks him out of that.
巴尼说，你陷入了困境，让他摆脱了困境。
And in this one, he's like, I want to go back.
在这一次，他就像，我想回去。
I want to go back to something that should have worked.
我想回到那些本来应该有效的事情上。
And it's safer than the new.
而且比新的更安全。
And that's consistent.
这是一致的。
In episode episode episode, it's a good little two episode arc there.
在剧集剧集中，这是一个很好的小两集弧线。
I never thought of it that quite that way.
我从来没有这么想过。
There's a book called Remember by Lisa Genova.
丽莎·吉诺娃（Lisa Genova）有一本书叫《记住》（Remember）。
and it talks about the sort of the science of memory and I'm fascinated by one thing where she talks about we expect that memory, we look at memory as, oh I can just go play the film from August 22nd such and such and such and that's not memory at all.
它谈到了记忆的科学，我对一件事很着迷，她谈到我们期待记忆，我们将记忆视为，哦，我可以去播放 8 月 22 日的电影，如此这般，那根本不是记忆。
You're not just on record all the time.
你不只是一直记录在案。
You have to make memories and you make memories from first kisses to 9-11 right, things that are just going to clearly stay with you.
你必须创造回忆，你要创造从初吻到9-11的回忆，这些事情会清楚地留在你身边。
You also make memories from speaking about them over and over and over, telling stories about this, and the notion of a good memory, like a clear memory about something is, you know, good luck, right?
你还可以通过一遍又一遍地谈论它们、讲述有关这些的故事来创造回忆，而美好记忆的概念，比如对某件事的清晰记忆，你知道，祝你好运，对吧？
You're immediately adding things to it.
您立即向其中添加内容。
And so, right, I think when we're going, you're going back to an old relationship, or to an old time, you're not going back to it.
所以，对，我认为当我们离开时，你会回到旧的关系，或者回到旧时光，你不会再回到过去了。
You're going to your current version of it, which is as good as you can do.
您将使用当前版本，这是您能做的最好的版本。
I mean, right now I'm writing this stuff about my father who passed away when I was 17 and I'm much more interested in what I think happened than what actually happened, than what he was actually like, because that doesn't matter anymore.
我的意思是，现在我正在写关于我父亲的故事，他在我 17 岁时去世了，我对我认为发生的事情更感兴趣，而不是实际发生的事情，而不是他实际上是什么样子，因为那已经不再重要了。
I write something about what my mother did or what his brother did.
我写一些关于我母亲或他兄弟所做的事情。
I don't go and fact check it, because who cares?
我不会去核实事实，因为谁在乎呢？
It's where it landed with me now that is the only current reality.
这就是它现在落在我身上的地方，这是当前唯一的现实。
Yeah.
是的。
It's kind of like we're all unreliable narrators like every single one of us is an unreliable narrator and and it also begs the question and I've seen people ask about this and this is a larger more global how I made your mother question is what we're watching in the quote unquote present day is that the story that Ted is telling the children or is it what really happened and he's sanitizing the story.
这有点像我们都是不可靠的叙述者，就像我们每个人都是不可靠的叙述者一样，这也引出了一个问题，我看到人们问过这个问题，这是一个更大的、更全球化的问题，我如何让你妈妈问我们今天在引文中看到的内容是特德正在告诉孩子们的故事，还是真实发生的事情，他正在净化这个故事。
Are we getting the unfiltered, unvarnished version and he's telling his kids a much more abridged, abbreviated version?
我们得到的是未经过滤、未经修饰的版本，而他正在告诉他的孩子们一个更加删节、缩写的版本吗？
Because it makes me think it's the latter because he says things like sandwiches and he, you know, he tries to protect them from some of the more grown-up aspects of the deal.
因为这让我认为是后者，因为他说了三明治之类的事情，而且他，你知道，他试图保护他们免受交易中一些更成熟的方面的影响。
So what do you think, Craig?
那么你觉得怎么样，克雷格？
Yeah, I mean, I think it's both, I think it toggles back and forth at our convenience, but it serves the joke for the moment.
是的，我的意思是，我认为两者都是，我认为它可以在我们方便的时候来回切换，但目前它只是个笑话。
But yeah, I think he's telling condensed versions and the audience are kind of going into inhabit more of that story, we're sort of transported.
但是，是的，我认为他讲的是浓缩版本，观众会更多地沉浸在这个故事中，我们有点被感动了。
He opened the door for us and we get to see things that aren't in literally in the story.
他为我们打开了大门，我们可以看到故事中没有的东西。
And presumably because the kids don't change, they don't have a costume change.
大概是因为孩子们没有改变，所以他们没有换服装。
And you guys made the joke at Comic Con that they've been held in the basement for like years.
你们在动漫展上开玩笑说他们已经被关在地下室好几年了。
Yeah, yeah, we shot a special thing once they were older.
是的，是的，当他们长大后，我们就拍了一些特别的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
The show.
演出。
But presumably this is just one long afternoon of tale telling, right?
但想必这只是讲故事的一个漫长的下午，对吧？
in theory, yeah, it sure is odd, right?
从理论上讲，是的，这确实很奇怪，对吧？
It's like, it's this is this endless like the story just keeps going.
就好像，故事就这样永无止境地继续下去。
And yeah, um, he's not literally telling every beat of every right in every episode, right, me impossible.
是的，嗯，他并没有真正讲述每一集中每一个权利的每一个节拍，对，我不可能。
But of course, the whole thing is kind of impossible anyway.
但当然，无论如何，整件事都是不可能的。
Yeah.
是的。
But I, but I love this idea that memory is not, uh, certainly not an infallible thing.
但我，但我喜欢这个想法，即记忆不是，呃，当然不是绝对可靠的东西。
Although there is a syndrome, I think very Lou Henner, the actress has this where she has like perfect memory.
虽然有一种综合症，但我认为非常像卢·亨纳，这位女演员在她拥有完美记忆力的地方就有这种综合症。
Do you know about this?
你知道这件事吗？
I do.
我愿意。
It's in the book.
书上有。
Should they talk all about her in this book.
他们应该在这本书里谈论她吗？
She can, you give her a date.
她可以，你给她一个约会。
She could tell you where she was, what she was wearing.
她可以告诉你她在哪里，她穿什么。
It's stunning.
太棒了。
Yes.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是的。
I don't have that.
我没有那个。
I do notice, though.
不过我确实注意到了。
And I think this is part of where Barney is the angel quality of Barney that we've been talking about.
我认为这就是我们一直在谈论的巴尼天使品质的一部分。
Certainly his double qualities are like much in evidence.
当然，他的双重品质是显而易见的。
But his angel quality is he does encourage, especially Ted to step into novelty and make memories because you don't remember an average night drinking in the bar with your friends, but you do remember licking a Liberty Bell in Philly.
但他的天使品质是他确实鼓励的，尤其是泰德，要踏入新奇事物并创造回忆，因为你不记得和朋友在酒吧喝酒的普通夜晚，但你确实记得在费城舔自由钟。
The things that you cited, Alec, are first kisses, 9-11, those are things that were wildly out of the ordinary or you weren't expecting to happen, good bad, all these things.
你提到的事情，亚历克，是初吻，9-11，这些事情非常不寻常，或者你没有预料到会发生，好坏，所有这些事情。
So I think I do think our memory gets much more emblazoned when something new or novel happens.
所以我认为当新的或新颖的事情发生时，我们的记忆会变得更加深刻。
Right.
正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
I just realized I saw Hamilton again.
我刚刚意识到我又见到了汉密尔顿。
I took my kids to see Hamilton and the characters and that are so aware that they're making history.
我带我的孩子们去看了汉密尔顿和剧中的人物，他们非常清楚自己正在创造历史。
History has its eyes on you.
历史的目光注视着你。
You know, they're so aware they're making history and I thought of Barney because Barney's like history has its eyes on me.
你知道，他们非常清楚自己正在创造历史，我想到了巴尼，因为巴尼就像历史一样注视着我。
I have to live every night and every night has to be legendary.
我必须活出每一个夜晚，每一个夜晚都必须是传奇。
going to talk about this.
来谈谈这个。
And it's it's hilarious that he thinks he's like that important like the found the founding fathers and him sort of having brothers, the founding brothers.
有趣的是，他认为自己像开国元勋一样重要，而且他有兄弟，开国元勋。
And yeah, it's it that is Barney's angel quality because he's it's true.
是的，这就是巴尼的天使品质，因为他是真的。
Most nights are forgettable, right?
大多数夜晚都是令人难忘的，对吧？
Most days are forgettable.
大多数日子都是令人难忘的。
What are the things that stand out?
有哪些突出的事情？
Well, Barney made those things stand out.
嗯，巴尼让这些事情脱颖而出。
And yeah, that's what this that's what the show is about.
是的，这就是这部剧的主题。
That's the purpose Barney serves to It had dead underscore and underscore robot dead end robot says the music in him.
这就是巴尼的目的。它有死下划线和下划线机器人死胡同机器人说他体内的音乐。
Yeah, it is very specific and very obscure.
是的，它非常具体，也非常晦涩。
I'd love to know your thoughts on the music.
我很想知道你对音乐的想法。
And if you have any favorite songs bands from the show also Josh, you being a musician.
如果你有任何最喜欢的歌曲乐队从节目中还有乔什，你是一名音乐家。
I wonder who your influences are.
我想知道你的影响力是谁。
So never a bad time to talk about music.
所以谈论音乐永远是一个好时机。
As the show is getting started here, Craig, you started a little bit about how it played a part and then Josh, are you being a musician?
当演出在这里开始时，克雷格，你开始介绍一下它是如何发挥作用的，然后乔什，你是一名音乐家吗？
I wonder who your influences are.
我想知道你的影响力是谁。
Yeah, I mean, well, we, Carter and I met by playing in bands together in college and then we started writing songs together and then we started writing comedy together.
是的，我的意思是，嗯，我们卡特和我在大学里一起玩乐队时认识的，然后我们开始一起写歌，然后我们开始一起写喜剧。
So music was the beginning of how Carter and I started working together and we kept doing that.
所以音乐是卡特和我开始合作的开始，我们一直这样做。
All the silly songs on the show, we wrote those and we often hand-picked like featured songs on the show.
节目中所有愚蠢的歌曲都是我们写的，而且我们经常精心挑选节目中的特色歌曲。
We also had an amazing music supervisor, Andy Gowin and obviously our composer, John Swayhart, wrote all this original music for the show and Brian Kim.
我们还有一位出色的音乐总监安迪·高文（Andy Gowin），显然我们的作曲家约翰·斯威哈特（John Swayhart）为节目和布莱恩·金（Brian Kim）创作了所有这些原创音乐。
Everybody who worked on the show knew how important music was to us.
每个参与该节目的人都知道音乐对我们来说有多重要。
Right away here in episode 4, we were very much featuring Bounce of Ashton featuring this song I love called We Rule the School.
就在第四集中，我们非常喜欢《Bounce of Ashton》，其中收录了我喜欢的歌曲《We Rule the School》。
Talking about Bounce of Ashton on the show and calling them out, and I was so happy for Bounce of Ashton that they would make money because we liked them.
在节目中谈论阿什顿的弹跳并大声喊出他们，我为阿什顿的弹跳感到非常高兴，因为他们会赚钱，因为我们喜欢他们。
They could pay each time this episode is rerun.
每次重播此集时他们都可以付费。
They're still getting some kind of check from from being on the show.
他们仍然从参加节目中获得某种支票。
And I, I, I always hope that would lead to me becoming best friends with them and spoilers that did not happen.
我，我，我一直希望这能让我成为他们最好的朋友，但剧透并没有发生。
But if they're listening, I really want to hang out sometime.
但如果他们在听，我真的很想找个时间出去玩。
But no, but you, we just, we, we did.
但是不，但是你，我们只是，我们，我们做到了。
We, Carter and I both loved a lot of the same music.
我们卡特和我都喜欢很多相同的音乐。
And it turned out that connected so much with Josh who was not a songwriter at that time but had an amazing, amazing taste in music.
事实证明，这与乔什有很大的联系，乔什当时不是词曲作者，但对音乐有着惊人的品味。
And you, you would make us mixes, Josh.
而你，你会让我们混音，乔希。
You would pitch us songs that got onto the show.
你会向我们推荐出现在节目中的歌曲。
We seem to all love like melodic, thoughtful, well-written, like really writerly songs like where the lyrics are very beautiful and interesting and kind of catch your ear in a different way.
我们似乎都喜欢旋律优美、深思熟虑、写得好的歌曲，就像真正的作家歌曲，比如歌词非常美丽、有趣，以不同的方式吸引你的耳朵。
And it's just, we, this, this episode is how I learned that you also love balance of action.
只是，我们，这一集，这集是我了解到你也喜欢行动平衡的方式。
And I was like, thank God, thank God Ted loves balance of action.
我当时想，感谢上帝，感谢上帝，特德喜欢行动的平衡。
Thank God our Ted, who we cast as this guy, Josh Radner, who we, we all both love music.
感谢上帝，我们的特德（Ted），我们选了他来扮演这个人，乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner），我们都热爱音乐。
And we, we're obsessive about music, right?
而我们，我们对音乐很着迷，对吧？
We talked about music all the time.
我们一直在谈论音乐。
And so I'd say it's hugely important in the show.
所以我想说这在节目中非常重要。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, you guys were great also about, um, I pitched you Cloud Call, who were my friends, we used, you were born, Jay May, my friend got, uh, I got her song on a show by playing it for you guys.
我的意思是，你们也很棒，嗯，我向你们推销了 Cloud Call，他们是我的朋友，我们用过，你们出生了，Jay May，我的朋友得到了，呃，我在节目中为你们播放了她的歌曲。
A couple others maybe, but I don't think, I mean, I don't think the songs were that obscure.
也许还有其他一些，但我不认为，我的意思是，我不认为这些歌曲那么晦涩难懂。
Like a couple of them were just like indie gems that maybe Andy Gowin scooped, you were ice-cooped.
就像他们中的几个人就像安迪·高文（Andy Gowin）挖到的独立宝石一样，你却被冰封了。
But, you know, the shins, band of horses, balance of action, like, there were a lot of heavy hitters, but maybe more from the indie world.
但是，你知道，小腿、马群、动作平衡等，有很多重量级人物，但也许更多来自独立世界。
And I think you're right that the world of how I met your mother music, what Andy Gowan also was the music soup on both my movies, great dude, fantastic taste in music.
我认为你是对的，我遇见你母亲的音乐世界，安迪·高恩也是我两部电影中的音乐汤，伟大的家伙，美妙的音乐品味。
But I think it was more like the music was inspired by the themes of the show, you know, it was like literate, thoughtful, funny, clever, ironic, you know.
但我认为这更像是音乐受到了节目主题的启发，你知道，它就像有文化、深思熟虑、有趣、聪明、讽刺，你知道。
Yeah.
是的。
And how music and memory are so intertwined.
音乐和记忆如何如此紧密地交织在一起。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
Right.
正确的。
Very in this episode, that's what it is.
在这一集里，就是这样。
Yeah.
是的。
That song.
那首歌。
He wants to go back into that song.
他想回到那首歌。
He wants to climb back into that balance of action.
他想重新回到行动的平衡状态。
It's the kind of songs that soundtrack your life.
这是一种为你的生活配乐的歌曲。
Yeah.
是的。
wistful and, you know, as the scenery rolls by when you're on a train or something, you know, and you're thinking about things.
渴望，你知道，当你在火车上或其他什么地方时，风景滚滚而过，你知道，你正在思考一些事情。
As far as my songwriting goes or my influences, I mean, they're so vast.
就我的歌曲创作或我的影响而言，我的意思是，它们是如此巨大。
I'm actually going to be on this podcast where I had to pick seven songs that represent seven phases of my life.
实际上，我要参加这个播客，我必须挑选七首代表我人生七个阶段的歌曲。
And it was a fascinating thought experiment.
这是一个令人着迷的思想实验。
But, But yeah, I mean, I have some Alzheimer's like Damien Rice's album, oh, Joni Mitchell's album Blue.
但是，但是，是的，我的意思是，我有一些阿尔茨海默氏症，比如达米安·赖斯的专辑，哦，乔尼·米切尔的专辑《蓝色》。
I grew up in a house with a lot of like John Denver and Barry Manolo and Jim Croci and Bob Dylan and Simon and Garfunkel and classical and show tunes like just all over the place.
我长大的房子里有很多像约翰·丹佛、巴里·马诺洛、吉姆·克罗奇、鲍勃·迪伦、西蒙和加芬克尔这样的人，古典音乐和表演音乐到处都是。
So my thing is like you said Craig, like I just love good melody and smart lyrics.
所以我的事情就像克雷格你说的那样，我只是喜欢美妙的旋律和聪明的歌词。
Like I want to be told a story in a song.
就像我想听歌里讲一个故事一样。
And the songs have become part of our story, and all of us, when we talk about memories, we can hear the songs of that chapter in our life in a song.
而歌曲已经成为我们故事的一部分，我们所有人，当我们谈论回忆时，我们都可以在一首歌中听到我们生命中那一章的歌曲。
I think almost maybe a smell can do this too, but a song can bring you, can transport you back in time more than anything, like a magic trick level transportation for your brain.
我想几乎也许一种气味也可以做到这一点，但是一首歌可以带你，比任何东西都更能带你回到过去，就像你的大脑的魔术级别的运输一样。
And I think that's why music's important to this show.
我认为这就是为什么音乐对这个节目很重要。
That is this, you know, time travel backwards into this life before his kids, and he wants to share what life was like and music as part of that.
这就是，你知道，时间旅行回到他的孩子之前的生活，他想分享生活是什么样的，以及音乐作为其中的一部分。
Our friend, Joel Viratello, he's had a theory that he's never tested out, but he said, if you're in the middle of something that you absolutely love, you just love this, this time in your life, you love this trip, he said, quickly, go put on a song and play it a few times so that later on that song can bring you back to this place.
我们的朋友乔尔·维拉泰罗（Joel Viratello）有一个从未被检验过的理论，但他说，如果你正在做一件你绝对喜欢的事情，你就会喜欢这个，在你生命中的这个时候，你喜欢这次旅行，他说，快点，放一首歌，播放几次，这样稍后这首歌就能把你带回到这个地方。
I love this thing.
我喜欢这个东西。
Also, Craig, you and I wrote some songs together.
另外，克雷格，你和我一起写了一些歌曲。
We can, we can talk about architecture studio one for you wrote some very stupid songs together in college.
我们可以，我们可以谈论建筑工作室一，因为你在大学里一起写了一些非常愚蠢的歌曲。
This is a question for me, though, the person didn't know it was.
这对我来说是一个问题，但那个人并不知道。
So look at how giddy you are that there's a question for you.
所以看看你有一个问题要问你有多头晕。
You look like fucking Christmas morning right now.
你现在看起来就像他妈的圣诞节早晨。
So they didn't know it was, but Craig, this is something about the show.
所以他们不知道是这样，但是克雷格，这是关于这个节目的。
Breathe for you go, bribe for you go.
呼吸让你走，贿赂让你走。
This isn't specifically about the return of the short episode, though I absolutely love all the sock monkeys in.
这并不是专门关于短集的回归，尽管我非常喜欢里面所有的袜子猴。
I find hilarious.
我觉得很搞笑。
I just want to ask why all the websites the creators made were taken down and asked if you knew about them, what your involvement or knowledge was about them.
我只是想问为什么创作者制作的所有网站都被撤下，并询问您是否了解它们，您对它们的参与或了解程度如何。
As an 18-year-old, I found out they used to exist but none of them work anymore except Barney's blog, which bear might not be real.
作为一个 18 岁的孩子，我发现它们曾经存在过，但除了巴尼的博客之外，它们都不再起作用了，那只熊可能不是真的。
I don't know what that is.
我不知道那是什么。
And the GNP website.
还有国民党网站。
I was so sad I wanted to see them so bad.
我很伤心，非常想见到他们。
So Craig, go on and talk a little bit about.
那么克雷格，请继续谈谈。
Okay.
好的。
I think the only thing to say here is we should call the studio and ask because because I think the studio had bogged these domain names and it's probably they ran out and expired and the studio changed hands, right?
我认为这里唯一要说的是我们应该打电话给工作室询问，因为我认为工作室已经陷入了这些域名的泥潭，很可能它们已经用完并过期了，工作室易手了，对吗？
Like it's like a different ownership and like it's so they're, I don't know.
就像不同的所有权一样，我不知道。
I just think we lost track of keeping.
我只是觉得我们失去了保存的踪迹。
They should.
他们应该。
They should have it.
他们应该拥有它。
We should have it.
我们应该拥有它。
They should be up.
他们应该起来了。
They should put them all up.
他们应该把它们全部放上来。
They should open source them like Wikipedia and let how I met your mother fans run the Goliath National Bank website, Garnie's blog.
他们应该像维基百科一样开源它们，并让我如何认识你母亲的粉丝运行歌利亚国家银行网站，即加尼的博客。
All the other ones.
所有其他的。
Yeah.
是的。
Okay.
好的。
published at some point.
在某个时候发布。
It's a great, you're right.
这是一个伟大的，你是对的。
You should exist.
你应该存在。
Brilliant observation.
出色的观察力。
All I can say is, sorry, maybe we can get them back.
我只能说，抱歉，也许我们可以把它们找回来。
I don't know.
我不知道。
They would appear in the script, and either you would come to me or me and Jesse, who worked with me, who's your brother-in-law, or we would come to you and say, hey, we can really do this website.
他们会出现在剧本中，要么你来找我或我和杰西，他和我一起工作，他是你的姐夫，要么我们来找你说，嘿，我们真的可以做这个网站。
We'd build this little website thing.
我们会建立这个小网站。
We'd ask 20th to get the URL.
我们会要求 20th 获取 URL。
And yeah.
是的。
Now, like, side-quest, we have to do this.
现在，就像支线任务一样，我们必须这样做。
We have to have to get these back.
我们必须把这些拿回来。
Do you know what I feel?
你知道我的感受吗？
I feel like it's still like somewhat relatively early days of of internet in some ways like 2005, 2007.
我觉得从某些方面来说，互联网仍然处于相对早期的时期，比如 2005 年、2007 年。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Like we were one of the first shows doing this like where you would drop the name of a website and then people would know kind of wink, wink that it that to go to it.
就像我们是最早这样做的节目之一一样，你会放下一个网站的名称，然后人们会眨眼，眨眼就知道要访问它。
You're supposed to go to it and there will be something there and we would often work very hard generating the content to put on there.
你应该去那里，那里会有一些东西，我们经常会非常努力地生成要放在那里的内容。
And yeah, and we were You're proud of it.
是的，我们是你为此感到自豪。
There was good stuff on there.
那里有好东西。
It gave this feeling like a secret handshake with the fans and the feeling that the universe of the show exists in the world.
给人一种就像是与粉丝秘密握手的感觉，以及节目的宇宙存在于世界的感觉。
We were really proud of that stuff and yeah, I would love to come back.
我们真的为这些东西感到自豪，是的，我很想回来。
You know, for a brief moment there, I think it was in season 9, we made a website that was a collection of all the websites because we got it all together.
你知道，有那么一小会儿，我想是在第九季，我们制作了一个网站，它是所有网站的集合，因为我们把它们都整合在一起了。
We got it together.
我们一起搞定了。
It's gone.
它消失了。
It's dead and gone.
它已经死了，消失了。
I mean, we can bring it back.
我的意思是，我们可以把它带回来。
We can resurrect it.
我们可以复活它。
Wasn't there something in this episode to turn the shirt to where Ted doesn't head say in some sort of the awkward way.
这集里不是有什么东西可以把衬衫转到特德没有以某种尴尬的方式说的地方吗？
Like the clip is going viral on the internet.
就像这段视频在互联网上疯传一样。
Or something like this.
或者类似的东西。
I have internet on my phone.
我的手机可以上网。
I have internet on my phone now.
我的手机现在可以上网了。
I have internet on my phone.
我的手机可以上网。
That is very 2000 five.
那是2000年的五个。
I love seeing the trio.
我喜欢看三人组。
He pulls out his trio to make the call.
他拿出他的三人组去打电话。
Oh my God, his trio.
天哪，他的三人组。
Oh my God, my phone gets internet now.
天哪，我的手机现在可以上网了。
That was it.
就是这样。
Oh, it's so sad.
哦，太难过了。
Okay.
好的。
Okay, so this last question here.
好的，最后一个问题就在这里。
Open is the first of the going back and making asking about something you wrote that maybe you would do differently now.
开放是回顾并询问你写的东西的第一步，也许你现在会做不同的事情。
We've sort of hinted at, oh yeah, we're gonna talk about those things.
我们有点暗示，哦，是的，我们要讨论这些事情。
Maybe just sort of get the conversation started now.
也许现在就开始谈话吧。
Obviously, if you're gonna write comedy with a thought to, will this be funny in 20 years, there will be no more comedy writing.
显然，如果你写喜剧的时候想的是，20 年后这会很有趣，那么就不会再有喜剧写作了。
But Ryan Levy says, how would, Ryan Levy says, how would you reflect on the beat up a girl comment at the end felt like a pretty diabolical punchline to me.
但瑞安·利维说，瑞安·利维说，你会如何反思最后一个女孩被殴打的评论对我来说就像是一个非常邪恶的妙语。
Yeah, I don't I don't love it.
是的，我不喜欢，我不喜欢。
Yeah, I think I think in general we will talk about some clunkers that didn't age well.
是的，我想总的来说，我们会讨论一些陈旧的旧车。
There's definitely there's way worse ones than that, but that idea, I don't think we would write it that way today.
肯定还有比这更糟糕的事情，但我认为我们今天不会那样写。
I have a little nine year old daughter who takes Taekwondo and is really good at it.
我有一个九岁的小女儿，她学跆拳道，而且非常擅长。
She's almost nine.
她快九岁了。
And she's like a little green belt and Taekwondo.
而她就像一条小绿带和跆拳道。
And she is fierce.
而且她很凶。
She could absolutely kick my ass in there.
她绝对可以在那里踢我的屁股。
She's trying to teach me how to do it.
她正在尝试教我怎么做。
And I feel like she could defeat me.
我觉得她可以打败我。
I like, so the idea of doing a joke like that just rings so differently in my ears now and it feels a little, 20 years ago.
我喜欢，所以讲这样一个笑话的想法现在在我耳边听起来是如此不同，感觉有点像 20 年前的感觉。
It feels a little, my phone has internet now.
感觉有点，我的手机现在可以上网了。
The level, not age and grade.
级别，而不是年龄和年级。
But I do think that the show was always, is sometimes explicitly but most more implicitly asking questions about gender, what does it mean to be a man?
但我确实认为这个节目总是，有时明确但大多数更含蓄地提出有关性别的问题，作为一个男人意味着什么？
What does it mean to be a woman?
作为一个女人意味着什么？
We showed strong women and we showed the softer side of men all the time.
我们一直展现女性坚强的一面，也一直展现男性温柔的一面。
That's why that's another reason that joke isn't great.
这就是为什么这个笑话不好的另一个原因。
Who were trying to work through some of the masculine script.
他们试图完成一些男性剧本。
I don't want to impose too much on this, but there's this kind of, I had said, I used to say that how I met your mother at it's heart was like a kind of gender flip, right?
我不想对此强加太多，但有这样一种，我说过，我曾经说过，我如何在内心深处遇见你的母亲就像一种性别翻转，对吗？
You had Marshall and Ted being these incredibly sensitive guys who wanted to drink cocoa by the fire and be in relationships.
马歇尔和泰德是非常敏感的人，他们想在火边喝可可并建立关系。
And then you had these women who were much more kind of no nonsense, like cut to the chase, not very sentimental, Lily and Robin.
然后你会看到这些女性，她们更加没有废话，喜欢开门见山，不太感伤，莉莉和罗宾。
And then you had Barney who was kind of this parody of hypermasculinity.
然后你就有了巴尼，他是一种对超级男子气概的模仿。
Um, yeah.
嗯，是的。
So I think it was like trapped between two worlds in a way and that's where some of the detention exists, but also some of the unfortunate kind of, um, it was a negotiation, right?
所以我认为这在某种程度上就像被困在两个世界之间，这就是一些拘留存在的地方，但也有一些不幸的，嗯，这是一场谈判，对吗？
Because you guys were also trying to negotiate with the network.
因为你们也在尝试与网络谈判。
Like you wanted to be like seen as a tough cool show, but you also wanted to like put these vulnerable male characters.
就像你想被视为一部强硬酷炫的节目，但你也想把这些脆弱的男性角色展现出来。
Like you centered them, right?
就像你将它们居中一样，对吗？
So it was always a tricky thing.
所以这始终是一件棘手的事情。
Like you weren't exactly smashing the patriarchy, but you were doing something revolutionary in your own way.
就像你并没有完全粉碎父权制，但你正在以自己的方式做一些革命性的事情。
Yeah, I definitely wanted to.
是的，我绝对想这么做。
That was definitely the aesthetic of the show.
这绝对是这部剧的美学。
And it is a gender flip right away in the pilot.
在试播集中，性别就发生了转变。
But Barney's Barney, right?
但巴尼的巴尼，对吗？
Barney will say and do things that are different from what Ted Marshall might say or do.
巴尼的言行与泰德·马歇尔的言行不同。
And just like Archie Bunker would say things on all in the family that his daughter and her husband found reprehensible and racist and terrible.
就像阿奇·邦克（Archie Bunker）会对家里所有人说一些他的女儿和她的丈夫认为应受谴责、种族主义和可怕的事情一样。
And Archie had to be Archie in that show.
阿奇必须是那个节目中的阿奇。
And Barney has to be Barney in this show.
巴尼在这个节目中必须是巴尼。
And not everybody is equally as evolved in the way they speak about things.
并不是每个人在谈论事物的方式上都同样进化。
And that sense, like, there's that weird thing of, if I'm being true to this character, they might say something like this, right?
那种感觉，就像，有一种奇怪的事情，如果我忠于这个角色，他们可能会说这样的话，对吧？
But then there's, if they say it too much and it feels like it's becoming literal, like it's the show's point of view.
但如果他们说得太多，感觉就像是字面意思，就像是节目的观点一样。
That's when it's bad.
到时候就不好了。
You want it to be the character's point of you not to show his point of view.
你希望这是角色的观点，而不是表现他的观点。
But I do think there's a kind of modern tendency that's not always unfortunate, but sometimes unfortunate, which is the idea that if a character in a show says something reprehensible, it's the point of view of the show or the writers.
但我确实认为有一种现代趋势并不总是不幸的，但有时是不幸的，那就是如果节目中的角色说了一些应受谴责的事情，那是节目或编剧的观点。
And that's often not true at all.
但事实往往并非如此。
Like it's the opposite, right?
好像是相反的，对吧？
That's not how writing works.
写作不是这样的。
That's how writing works, right?
这就是写作的方式，对吗？
That's there be no great, I think about Shakespeare.
那没有什么伟大的，我想到莎士比亚。
I think like, like, like Shakespeare's like, yeah, go like it makes sense.
我想，就像，就像莎士比亚一样，是的，去吧，就像它有道理一样。
Every greed work of art has a horrible character in it or several.
每一件贪婪的艺术作品中都有一个或多个可怕的特征。
Right?
正确的？
And it is.
确实如此。
Yeah.
是的。
It's an interesting.
这是一个有趣的。
You're always trying to find that level where you seem like you're not.
你总是试图找到你看起来并非如此的水平。
The show is not endorsing a bad thing, but you're also being true to who a character is.
该剧并不是在支持坏事，但你也忠于角色是谁。
And that is a tough dance.
这是一场艰难的舞蹈。
I won't say we got it right every time.
我不会说我们每次都做对了。
Sometimes you, you hope that your audience sees it the way you do, and maybe most of the audience does, but some percentage of it hears it as the literal endorsement by the show as if the show is point of view is that that's when that's when I feel we we fail a little bit.
有时你，你希望你的观众以你的方式看待它，也许大多数观众都是这样，但其中有一部分人将其视为节目的字面认可，就好像节目是观点一样，那就是我觉得我们有点失败的时候。
If too many people think that way, I think we we didn't communicate it clearly enough.
如果太多人这么想，我想我们沟通得还不够清楚。
I think some of that happened sometimes with Barney and in other ways, but I like to think that, for example, with Barney, he mostly plays as a parody of something, not an endorsement of something, but I know that not everybody took it that way.
我认为其中一些有时会以其他方式发生在巴尼身上，但我喜欢认为，例如，对于巴尼来说，他主要是对某些事物的模仿，而不是对某些事物的认可，但我知道并不是每个人都这么认为。
That was the intention.
这就是目的。
It's all I can say.
我只能说这么多了。
All right, that's what I got for this week.
好吧，这就是我这周的收获。
Great questions.
很好的问题。
Great question.
Thank you for those questions.
谢谢你提出这些问题。
Hey, Craig, you having a good time doing this podcast?
嘿，克雷格，你做这个播客玩得开心吗？
I'm having a really good time, Trins.
我玩得很开心，特林斯。
I like it.
我喜欢它。
You have a good time doing this podcast.
你玩这个播客玩得很开心。
I better be.
我最好是这样。
It's all I do.
这就是我所做的一切。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I am, I am, and we're so grateful.
嗯，我是，我是，我们非常感激。
A lot of people are listening and writing in, and it just feels like we're getting to sit around a campfire and share these, how I made my mother's story.
很多人都在听和写，感觉就像我们坐在篝火旁分享这些，我是如何创作我母亲的故事的。
So thank you for joining us.
感谢您加入我们。
Thank you for continuing to journey with us.
感谢您继续与我们一起旅行。
We got a lot more to go, but it's been a blast, so thanks a lot.
我们还有很多事情要做，但这真是太棒了，所以非常感谢。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
Olsen's off again in New York City.
奥尔森再次出发前往纽约。
How we made your mother is hosted an executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯担任执行制片人主持。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Webb 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Pointe de Blue Studios, artwork by John Morrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Pointe de Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，作品由 John Morrow 设计。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lowly Kennedy and Elliot Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的 NYC，特别感谢 Lowly Kennedy 和 Elliot Connards。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemajormother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on Substac.
在 Substac 上订阅 Josh Riders 的时事通讯。
Read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society, also on Substac.
阅读克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您还可以在 Substac 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》(Dead Father Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集的制作得到了 Backyard Ventures 的支持，并由 Tink Media 提供营销。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。